it's great to welcome back to the
program today grace blakely who is a
staff writer at
tribune magazine and also author of the
book
stolen how to save the world from
financialization
uh grace it's great to have you back on
today great to be here thanks for having
me
so okay let's i want to talk about
whether there will really be
any longer term changes to the economy
into the world of work from the pandemic
you know we we just kind of generally
have this understanding that
things that seem like oh we're never
going back humans
forget humans re-adapt and things sort
of return to the mean
in in many cases are there aspects
of work and or the relationship of
people to the economy
particularly in western economies that
you think will be permanently altered as
a result of the pandemic
well i think as with any crisis what
happens next is really going to depend
on
what we demand and uh and how we kind of
choose to reorganize society when we
when we emerge from it
um i don't think that we will see a kind
of return to normal whatever normal
um was because i mean even before the
pandemic we had a lot of quite
deep problems with the global economy
everything from this kind of long-term
stagnation and productivity and
investment through to a stagnation in
wages
through to uh the kind of massive debt
crisis that uh that we were going
through
you know in the us people were talking
about a corporate debt bubble um even
before the pandemic started which of
course fed
into a lot of the the problems that we
saw at the start um so there were
already all these kind of
deep-seated issues that i wrote about in
my my first book that you mentioned
they're stolen
um so obviously going back to that kind
of normal
would not be desirable we also then had
some kind of more um i suppose longer
term structural problems to deal with so
things like you know obviously climate
breakdown
uh global inequality inequality within
nations as well
and some of those things have gotten
worse over the course of the pandemic so
if we
we look at inequality for example um
globally
we've seen this big divergence in
outcomes between
wealthier states that have been able to
tackle the pandemic um
have been able to have kind of big you
know stimulus programs big uh programs
to support workers and businesses
and states in the global south which uh
have suffered from the largest outflow
of capital ever recorded
as a result of the pandemic and are
struggling just to be able to kind of
provide the basic services that their
populations
need let alone put in place the measures
that are going to allow them to recover
um and actually a lot of them are kind
of on the verge of defaulting on their
debts and then you know they're not able
to access the vaccine either so
that divergence is going to be really
really problematic inequality within
countries
we've seen this big divide between
people who've been able to amass
savings and who will come out of the
pandemic go out and spend all that money
potentially driving a bit of inflation
and everyone else who maybe has actually
seen their debt
increase and is struggling to make ends
meet so that divide is going to increase
as well
and really what happens next is all
going to be shaped by
policy by you know whether or not we
have a kind of just
um recovery or whether we see the same
sorts of policies as what we saw after
the financial crisis
where the costs of that crisis were
largely borne by working people
to pick one micro issue and see whether
you think it's really relevant to the
bigger picture or it's just something
people are liking to write articles
about
uh there's this idea that okay take
manhattan
um there saw this empty office space in
manhattan because
of work from home and small businesses
moving out and big businesses will re
reduce their footprint and just reduce
the amount of square footage
and then you read an analysis which
takes a sort of conservative view on it
which is
yeah you know rents will go down a few
percent in the immediate but it's still
manhattan it's still really expensive
and then
three four years from now if there's not
another pandemic they'll probably sort
of be back to being close to where they
were
and some of the big offices will be
replaced with
co-working spaces and like it won't
really change the big picture in a
serious way
something like that do you think that
that even ranks when we think about like
the systemic changes or is the analysis
that it's a couple percentage points and
it won't really make a difference is the
correct analysis
i mean the big driver of um like
real estate prices at the moment is not
necessarily demand it's more speculation
particularly in big cities um so in
places like manhattan and london
um there has not been the kind of fall
in uh in rents and particularly in
actual house prices that you would
assume would happen
as people leave the capital so in london
for example the population has fallen
according to some estimates by around
700
000 um since the pandemic started which
is huge
and there hasn't really been too much of
an impact on rents or
uh or real estate prices it's different
in different parts of the market but
broadly speaking things haven't changed
dramatically
and of course the main reason for that
is um quantitative easing
it's this policy adopted by central
banks of creating new money to purchase
assets from private investors
which is pumping tons and tons and tons
of cash
into the financial system uh i think the
last time i checked it was about nine
trillion dollars worth of new money had
been created predominantly by the big
four central banks
to try and prop up the financial system
and actually to try and keep asset
prices high
this is what central banks are trying to
do at the moment they're trying to keep
equities higher trying to keep real
estate prices high
basically because you know if those
prices were to fall
that could create um a wider financial
crisis uh basically because you know
some of that is used as collateral for
lending and if you start to see that
fall you get a kind of debt deflation
cycle of the kind that we saw
during the financial crisis so policy
makers and central bankers are actually
going for high asset prices or at least
stable asset prices
and this model of quantitative easing is
how they're doing it and that's likely
to be with us
for quite some time now um a lot of it
is going to depend on what happens in
the rest of the economy
you know to do with inflation and
whatever but broadly speaking central
bankers know that the big thing driving
asset prices at the moment
is their policies and if those policies
stop you could see
quite a significant fall in asset prices
which would have kind of negative
implications in terms of financial
stability
but which would actually probably
correct the massive wealth inequality
that we've seen really you know just go
through the roof of the course the
pandemic people like jeff bezos becoming
extraordinarily wealthy basically
because money's being plowed into amazon
shares
because of central bank policy the same
thing is happening in uh
with real estate as well um so unless we
see like a big shift in policy
that probably isn't going to change then
again it is hard to see how the pattern
that we've seen over the last kind of 40
years of just constantly increasing
um house prices can continue forever
so you know it's a real question as to
the interaction between policy
and you know whether or not we see
another shock that does actually lead to
some sort of correction but
i wouldn't put any money on house prices
properly falling in the kind of short to
medium term
yeah speaking of that i i'd be
interested to hear from you if you have
advice for for my audience about how to
interpret i mean just to give an example
about
the home prices because it's something
that that's quite interesting right now
during 2020 um when
demand started to grow in the united
states in suburbs and smaller cities for
people saying hey maybe i'll just get a
bigger place
a little bit further out work from home
etc donald trump
cheered this on and said listen we're
doing okay look at home prices they're
actually up like this is a sign that
things are good
in an interview with newsmax two days
ago donald trump
said this inflation stuff is out of
control
look at what homes are costing at this
point in time no one can get lumber and
of course it's a very transparent
political attack on on joe biden but
is there some empirical objective
analysis we can do
of to what degree is it good that the
home
prices have gone up and to what degree
is it a problem
i mean it depends whether or not you own
a home right and this is really the kind
of
big divide that we're seeing in politics
at the moment i think it explains a lot
of the age divide
and also to an extent the kind of
regional divide that we're seeing in
politics
is the older homeowners um
which is a group that was broadly
created
um during the 1980s as you saw the
liberalization of the financial system
right people were better able to get
mortgages
they could you know purchase homes in
the uk you had mass sell-off
of um formerly publicly owned housing
and it created this class of homeowners
who were able to take advantage of that
massive increase in house prices that
we've seen over the last 50 years become
very wealthy
and as a result become very conservative
uh because you know if you're like on
the verge of retirement or you're
already retired you have a lot of wealth
stored up in your home you have a lot of
wealth stored up in your pension
what do you want the main thing that you
want is to see house prices stable
and assisted stock prices going up right
and price prices actually going up as
well
if you're a young person that's the
opposite of what you want right
and certainly with house prices like you
are probably
struggling to get on the on the on the
housing ladder maybe struggling to get a
mortgage maybe you don't have like a
full-time job
that uh is the kind of job that will
allow you to get a mortgage
um maybe you're like self-employed or
precariously employed so you know you're
really struggling often to get on the
housing ladder especially if you're
looking in one of these big cities
um and that is often you're also paying
extremely high rents in the private
rented sector right and you know parts
of london people are paying up to like
50
of their salaries in rent which is just
extraordinary um
and so obviously that means you have an
interest in things being different right
so this divide between people who want
things to broadly stay the same want
house prices to stay the same
and who are as a result becoming quite
conservative
out of this desire to hold on to the
kind of gains that they've made
versus everyone else who's being shut
out of that system
is i think probably the most important
divide in politics at the moment so so
in a sense it's sort of a political
football in the sense that you can argue
that housing prices being up
is good or bad depending on for which
group group
you are talking and also what sort of
underlying implications you think it
points to about the economy at large
yeah exactly and i mean you know
economists will will say oh well house
price is going up is good because you're
going to have
the wealth effect of people feeling
wealthier because their house is worth
more
so maybe you know taking the equity out
of that house and going out and spending
it in the economy which is good for the
economy
i mean you know fine obviously if you
were to see a massive fall in house
prices without any corrective measures
put in place
that could have negative implications um
for like overall growth but actually
there's a structural problem here which
is the
you know the fact that economic growth
relies on constantly
increasing wealth inequality right and
like constantly
returns you know increasing at the very
top of the the wealth spectrum
is not sustainable last thing i want to
um talk about is you know in the united
states
republicans for decades now have been
saying this government spending
program is going to make inflation off
the charts obama's
stimulus is going to push inflation off
the charts
uh trump's first coveted stimulus second
covets them okay and and they were
more or less wrong all along and
inflation has been quite quite stable
we now have a situation finally where
we're starting to see some higher
inflation numbers
some of it is because we're comparing to
the second quarter of 2020 when there
was a total demand
collapse so part of that may be an
artifact of that
it still sort of remains to be seen
how should we interpret that like is the
idea of the inflationary spiral when
governments do stuff something we can
just
put to bed at this point or is there
anything to it
people get very hysterical about
inflation and this was kind of a proper
neoliberal talking point during the
1980s
basically you know at that time
inflation was
people weren't actually worried about
inflation i mean they would frame it as
being worried about inflation because
they could say well it's the price of
the goods and services that you're
buying that's going up
really it was a mechanism to discipline
organized labor
um so you know you saw uh well for
example in the u.s with the volcker
shock
interest rates go through the roof um it
created a kind of worldwide economic
crisis so a debt crisis in the global
south but it was also used as a tool
to create mass unemployment so that the
labor
unions could be broken and this kind of
neoliberal model could be set up
and since then we haven't had the same
kinds of um you know back then yeah
there were kind of some issues with
inflation i mean a lot of it was
actually driven by the oil price spike
rather than anything else but
you know inflation hasn't really been
too much of an issue and actually since
the financial crisis it's been too low
i mean you can think about um
inflationary pressure as something that
happens when
um the output gap closes so that's the
gap between the amount of stuff that we
could be producing
if every resource was being put to use
and the amount of stuff we're actually
producing right
so when you get inflation it's because
you're starting to get to the point
where
all the resources that exist in the
economy are being used to their greatest
extent right or maybe more than
those resources are being used so you're
getting some pressure on prices
but when that isn't happening so you
know there's underemployment under
utilization of resources
you don't have inflationary pressure and
that's what we were seeing because there
was this big
shortage in demand that came from low
levels of investment low levels of
government spending
and just general kind of a lack of
optimism about what was going on in the
economy
legitimately so today what we're seeing
is
because it's less about the fact that
demand is going up demand is going up
and it will continue to go up
it's more about the fact that the actual
amount that we could produce
has contracted so much so that kind of
longer-term supply
side of the economy um has really become
much more constrained
a big reason for that is what's going on
in the rest of the world
and this is why it's really really
important for economies in the global
north aside from the kind of obvious
moral reasons
to pay attention to the global economy
because if you start to see you know um
say the indian variants spreading
throughout the global south
production shuts down right you can't
get access to the commodities that you
know
as massive importers countries like the
us and uk need just to kind of
get by then you will start seeing a huge
amount of inflation especially since you
have all these savings
um that middle-class people have and
that they want to go out and spend in
the economy
um so that's i think the biggest
potential pressure that we're going to
be seeing inflation-wise from now on
um and ultimately it's going to hurt
working-class people more than it's
going to hurt middle-class people
no question no question about that we've
been speaking with grace blakely staff
writer at tribune magazine and also
author of stolen how to save the world
from financialization
grace always great speaking with you and
you too thanks david